on prime crime
[Music]
it's the shooting that raised so many
questions
and then you give him the gun and then
he lays back and according to him
he falls asleep
[Music]
and a jury's decision that left trial
watchers confused
i don't think they necessarily thought
it out i don't know if y'all are
familiar with the georgia law but
yeah i have i'm a lawyer i've read the
law i've read the cases
hey there everybody i'm jesse weber and
welcome to prime crime
this is where we do a deeper dive into
the most high profile
and memorable true crime cases a
seemingly happy
successful couple go out for the evening
to have a good time
but only one of them makes it out alive
you want to have the worst feeling in
your life
with two surgeons
this is claude tex mciver a prominent
atlanta labor lawyer
so why is he speaking with police in
2016
well you can't talk about tex mciver
without talking about his wife
diane this was a couple that by all
accounts
had a fairy tale romance diane was a
self-made woman she started off
answering phones in an office worked her
way up to being an executive
very successful made millions of dollars
tax meantime
was a partner at a very prominent labor
law firm
here in atlanta very successful in his
own right as well
they ended up living in the same fancy
condo complex in a part of atlanta
called buckhead
they started dating and eventually got
together
they were very happy they were smitten
with each other
he worshipped the ground on which she
walked but tex and diane's love story
came to a screeching halt
on september 25th 2016.
after golfing earlier in the hot sun tex
and diane went to dinner with friends
craig stringer and danny joe carter
dianne
and uh
craig went home and we got in the car
danny was driving
for obviously
they drove back to atlanta uh in texas
suv
danny joe carter their good friend was
driving
uh diane was sitting in the front seat
and tex was in the back seat
the testimony was that they hit some
traffic uh
and that he had fallen asleep in the
back seat
that he woke up as they got off the
interstate and looked around him and
thought that they might have been in a
bad neighborhood it
seemed like every turn we made the
street was darker and there were more
people
yelling about i mean it was
kind of ambrose's hair on the back
mciver then asked diane to hand him his
gun
which was in the console of the car it's
at this point when the knight
takes a deadly turn he claims uh to have
fallen back asleep
and then claims that he jerked awake and
that is when the gun
went off i immediately called out i said
everybody
all right and dan joe said yes
and diane it was kind of slanted
and she said uh i've been shot worse
than that effect
and i immediately put my house around
her and try to determine
what was how bad it was after she was
taken to the hospital
diane mciver was pronounced dead
i was handling the gun and i
realized it was in my lap right and it
went off
the minute he said that is when a
problem i think arose
because no one's going to buy that a gun
simply went off
you need to actually pull the trigger
for it to go
off the motive for attacks to kill diane
in my opinion was one of the oldest
motives known to mankind and it was
greed he was a person that loved money
and he liked
uh being the big spender in the room as
he began to
age his ability to generate revenue for
the firm
diminished greatly tex was really
struggling
to make that same financial
goal that he had for himself every year
diane is continuing to financially
escalate her and when tex gets really
desperate he goes her and says hey
i need a loan she triggered the loan
such that a failure to pay her back the
money
would allow her the ability to take
ownership of the ranch which was his
pride and joy
diane is kind of putting her foot down
they are starting to have these little
snippy kind of arguments like you do
and i think tex was looking for a way
that he could
keep his ranch and
become financially solvent again
after investigators reviewed all the
evidence tex macgyver was eventually
indicted for the murder of diane
yet this prosecution was far from simple
this was the type of case that always
appeared at least to me to
to be nothing more than an accident you
have to first keep in mind that it
wasn't
tex mcgiver's decision to even get off
the exit
to put them in quote-unquote a
potentially dangerous area
and secondly it was his wife diane that
provided him with the gun
did he suddenly at after all these years
have an epiphany
in the back of the car after a full day
of golfing and drinking that this
was the time he was going to end his
wife's life
in front of a witness that could
potentially testify against him that
makes
absolutely no sense i think that what
macgyver was counting on is that he was
in the backseat
it was dark nobody could see what he was
doing
and he could pull this off and then he
could just claim
oh my god it was an accident danny jo
backed me up
up next we'll dig into the evidence
starting with the crime scene
which provides clues as to what happened
there
are instances when you could potentially
say that a gunshot wound was an accident
ricochet for example for this case there
was no indication that the bullet
changed its trajectory at all
[Music]
[Music]
in 2016 investigators are confronted
with a strange situation
an atlanta lawyer named tex mciver
explains that after a day of golf and
drinking
he accidentally shot and killed his wife
diane
as the couple were being driven in a car
by their friend
danny joe carter he says this was simply
a horrible accident
but prosecutors allege tex intended to
kill diane
over money including the fact that he
owed her
350 000 while tex
would be charged with murder a careful
look at the evidence begs the question
is it really first there's the issue
of why mackyver was holding the gun
the next thing i remember is we're going
down and then
the turn was made i said girls
where are we where are we and what's
happening right i
quickly said this is a big mistake and
we're in a place that we don't belong
right the area that they're talking
about is sort of in the downtown atlanta
area
it is known for being an area where a
lot of homeless people do congregate
that time of night tex macgyver says he
looks out the window and sees homeless
people and
is fearful that there might be a
carjacking or something along those
lines
[Applause]
and then you give him the gun and then
he lays back and according to him
he falls asleep what i'm so scared i
want you to give me my gun
but as soon as you give me the gun i'm
gonna go to sleep
i guess i just laid back again
and i went to sleep and joe came to a
stop
and
[Music]
the argument was that he woke up stunned
he didn't kind of know where he was
and pulled the trigger not realizing
what was going on and then didn't
remember
now some may say well that's kind of a
cockamamie you know story i don't really
believe it but
there's an argument to be made that it's
just as
possible that happened then that he made
a decision in the back of the vehicle to
shoot and kill
his wife over finances
[Music]
safety classes or anything like that
no all we can really tell the autopsy
is the track of the bullet through the
person's body
the pathway as the medical examiner
described it
was back to front right to left and
slightly downward
we hired an expert
reconstructionist when you look at that
trajectory it's a straight line
you can easily position macgyver's arm
at the time that the the gunshot was
fired and you know that it wasn't in his
lap like he said
the tex macgyver case wasn't just about
the physical evidence
but the behavior of the defendant too
for instance
once diane was shot it's important to
note which hospital
tex directed danny jo to go to
because tex macgyver was an employment
litigator
he had grady before
in litigation he knew that their
reputation
was that they were the best level one
trauma center
in this part of the country you are
a mere few blocks away from grady and
that's not where you go
order to take danny jo on this long
winding journey
through the city to try to get to emory
university hospital
which is not a trauma center that's a
research hospital
because he didn't want her to survive
don't want to survive
and it worked then again
if this was all part of machiver's
master plan
some things don't seem to add up
in cases where you would want someone to
die quickly
shooting them in the abdomen is not
really the way to go
why on earth wouldn't have shot her in
the head where it's guaranteed
that she's going to die the last thing
on earth you'd want is to have your wife
so
injured that you're going to spend the
rest of your life paying for her medical
bills
if this was in fact an accident tex
mciver
sure didn't help his case the peculiar
things he does
after the shooting are what lead
prosecutors to believe
this was murder like when he doesn't
immediately
call 9-1-1 instead the first call he
makes
is to his attorney his immediate
thought process was what do i need to do
to protect myself
how can i get away with this if you're
truly
an innocent person you are not calling
your lawyer first
i don't think there is anything to the
fact that he didn't call 9-1-1 why
because they were
again within four miles of a hospital
they weren't going to stop on the side
and wait for police to come
yet there's much more to what mcivor
said and did after the death of his wife
that left people uneasy
sir let me just be playing danny is
about to send me to prison
when we return
back in 2016 atlanta attorney claude tex
mciver recounts to police
how he accidentally shot and killed his
wife diane in a moving car
mciver claims he had his gun in his hand
as they were driving through a reported
rough neighborhood
but at one point he fell asleep with the
weapon on his lap
when the car came to a jolting stop he
says
he suddenly woke up and the gun went off
the odd circumstances of the killing at
first make this look like a mistake
not murder especially since mackiver
shot his wife in front of a witness
danny joe carter the couple's friend who
was driving the car
however it's what maciver does
afterwards
that changes the game in the days and
weeks after the shooting
the friends of both diane and tex
reported that
he wasn't really acting like what you
would expect a grieving
shocked husband to act like one of the
biggest red flags that prosecutors
raised was that he
put on a massive estate sale we're
talking
furs and purses and jewelry
thousands upon thousands of dollars of
diane macgyver's things
that he wanted to put up for auction
everybody seemed to think
that he was more fixated on how could he
benefit financially from diane's death
than he was about
grieving her death then there was the
voicemail
after it was reported danny joe carter
had hired a lawyer and might start
speaking more with police
mciver decided to call carter's husband
tommy lady sir let me just be playing
danny is about to send me to prison
please erase this this voicemail message
but call me
right away y'all have no idea the
problem this is causing
it's innocent but it's absolutely
nuclear for me
please please call me i gotta make sure
that i don't suffer any criminal uh
consequence to this
so i'm i'm gonna have to get to danny jo
and uh
and i'm thankful that they preserved uh
that information on their voicemail
because otherwise nobody would have
believed it the state would even allege
that mcivor
asked danny jo at the hospital to tell
the police
that she wasn't in the car he tried to
get it a lot to the police while they
were at the hospital
and and i think that um in an act of
desperation
you know the time for him to do this was
running out
in the end tex mciver was charged with
several crimes including malice murder
felony murder and influencing a witness
in 2018
his trial began she's been reduced now
to a simple number
except in the minds of the people
who loved her
stand up for diane if you're going to
murder someone
why do you shoot her in front of her
best friend
and try to sell that on you know to
hollywood or tv show and i'd say that's
a ridiculous plot
it makes no sense your verdict
should be not guilty
as to all counts in this indictment this
case proved to be so challenging for the
jury
that at one time they indicated to the
court they were undecided
yet after an incredible 27 hours of
deliberations
the jury finally came back with a
verdict
coming up what will be the fate for tex
macgyver
on count one murder we find the
defendant
i think all court shows are the same
we're talking about your father guilty
or not guilty guilty think again judge
caprio rules with common sense
i was having contractions i was rushing
to the hospital inspector quinn what
does justice demand
jail and compassion i'm going to take
the
circumstances into consideration the
best court experience i've had clearly
judge he's been in a court before
get caught in providence
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions welcome to prime
crime tonight another day of drama
between both sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the law on crime network is everywhere
and we invite
you inside the jury box this is law and
crime
guns are not my thing there were some
theories that
this had been done because of my need
for her money and so on it's just not
the case
it turns out she is very very successful
on her own right
coming the way she did but i was born
in 2018 a georgia jury had a difficult
decision to make
do they find claude tex mciver guilty of
murdering his wife diane
when he shot her from the back seat of a
moving car
on one hand mackiver's defense team
presented evidence that this was an
accident
when mackyver was startled awake in the
car
they also highlighted how it was
illogical that a man would intentionally
kill his wife in public
with a witness present namely the
couple's friend
danny joe carter who is driving the
vehicle
on the other hand the prosecution
highlighted problems in the couple's
marriage
they argued tex had a financial motive
to kill his wife
and they said he pointed the gun
directly at diane
after several days of deliberations the
jury
reached a verdict on count one
murder we finally defended not guilty
the first count in the indictment was
malice murder
and uh the verdict was not guilty
so it was like
on count two felony murder we find the
defendant
defendant guilty of felony murder i know
the defense was real disappointed
but i thought the evidence you know was
uh was pretty clear the jury
also found mciver guilty of aggravated
assault a felony firearms charge
and influencing a witness but did the
jury
make the right decision here there was
definitely some confusion there
malice murder uh would pretend that
somebody
intentionally tried to kill somebody
which was what the prosecution was
saying all along
but they came back and convicted him on
felony murder
uh with the underlying assumption being
that he
intentionally shot his wife to wound her
which was a little curious because
the prosecution never really put that
case on this became all the more
complicated
when we heard from one of the jurors was
this
shooting intentional and why
i don't me personally i don't think he
intended to shoot his wife but i think
he intentionally just shoots someone
so that was the recklessness in the case
one of the jurors sat and talked
mostly about the fact that this was a
reckless crime well reckless crime is
not an intentional
assault but the state's whole theory of
this is that he wanted her dead so that
he could get control over her money her
property
he would have been in control
so he wanted to perhaps incapacitate her
that's it
i don't i don't find that he wanted the
capacity or he did what he wanted to do
and that was for her not to be here but
it did not go his way
i don't remember a single piece of
evidence that would supported
a theory that he simply wanted to injure
his wife
i think they were torn between the
counts so they were like
all right let's just go in the middle i
don't think they necessarily thought it
out
i don't know if y'all are familiar with
the georgia law but yeah i have i'm a
lawyer i've read the law i've read the
cases so he wanted to
violently injure his wife but not kill
her so that he could get control
over their finances
correct whatever may have been the
reasoning the jury convicted
tex macgyver and while at sentencing he
explained his love and devotion to his
wife
darling you have brought me more joy and
fulfillment
that few men on this earth have ever
known
thank you and until we are together
again judge robert mcburney
sentenced macgyver to life in prison and
left him
with some harsh words i'll tell you
what's what's
most telling you had as much time as you
wanted to
share with me what you thought was
important for me to hear
and i didn't ever hear you say you're
sorry
for what you did to me that silence
speaks volumes
this is by far one of the more
controversial cases that we've ever
covered and yes that's given the
circumstances of the shooting and the
aftermath but
really it's because people even to this
day
still don't agree on the verdict as that
debate rages on
at the time of this taping a georgia
judge has denied mciver's request for a
new trial
but his appeal is moving forward to the
georgia supreme court
leaving texas future uncertain
that's all we have for you here on prime
crime leave us your comments on
instagram and twitter with the hashtag
prime
crime as always thank you for joining us
and until next time
be safe
[Music]
you